tour qu'on va le faire faire on va les
faire
tourner attend attend
mtenantten5
VO les ombres qui vont se détacher sur
le truc en face les pas trs
marqué
finale autorisé àage plus 05 08 alle 12
m
ça rien à voir no photos les a se
détachent pas
cinma c'est moins grave parce que
VO on les verra bouger quoi tu vois ah
ils sont dans le vent un peu
là
c'est beau
ça les ombres m voir sur du blanc c'est
ces ombres qui sont un
peuformé c'est vachement beau tu peux te
mettre un peu moins cul de plus de plus
en diagonale s'il te
plaît les zbres regarde les zbres devant
c'est vachement
beau
ch vraiment pas de de
contraste la à 48 plus
dégag il faudrait que tu peux dire que
le me soit au fond derrière le le mec
qui est derrière soit bien le dernier
quoi derrière le
chameau il faudrait que le mec est en
blanc derrière soit bien derrière le
dernier chameau et pas l'écart à gauche
qu'est-ce qui se passe là c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon
il est derrière les Ch
voilà bien re j'ai bien reu la
commission
merci merci à vous je F le dernier mec
derrière le chameau sinon il avait l'air
en décalage on se demander ce qu'il
foutait c'est beau les ombres regarde
les ombres à gauche voilà plus haut plus
haut voilà tu les vois les ombres
auudessus voilà
merci il se voit pas beaucoup B le mec
derrière il fait la merde hein lui he
oh c'est beau ça
le
le peu
général
zoomer doucement pour t'élargir un petit
peu dessus attends il rentre dans
l'ombre donc ça d'ombre allez
vas-y tu peux monter pour
élargir les chameau
et monter en reculant un peu tu peux je
sais
pas c'est que les
hélicoptèreit vachement be ça
regarde
c'est Fox golfbec bravo
Fox appelez le kil bravo Fox ou le kbec
BRA Fox le
Fox je vous
écoute et synotique
Pest Rapp cprour on raellera
cpret alle tu peux redescendre pour une
valeur moyenne
pareil
ça c'est beau ça les
ombres prends to un petit
peu
comment ils vont passer
là allez
arrête-toi
merci
et le dernier le mec il regarde et lui
là il a pas envie de bosser lui il
regarde il fait que regarderé il comme
ça c'est c'est
top il a pas envie
lui tu peux lui dire alors Disle
peut-être tu veux qu' ne regarde pas bah
sinon ça c'est un peu dommage quand même
hein bon d n pas envie de le faire il
rentre rentre chez lui
hein vasy à la face un
peu oh les couleurs au fond regarde ce
que c'est beau regarde derrire
inro pas de
C
cle
arriv
vas-y Franky qui descends
ok les ombres derrière des
chameaux génial ça les
ombres tu ve faire un au télé après les
chameaux son n derrière là ou j'arrive
j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive
j'arrive c'est très beau ça sortir du
champ les
malheureusement
[Musique]
ça va
êreardve c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
très très
grave
de retrouver si on va retrouver
ça sur une
lune
derrière voilà ça arrive regarde tu te
recules un peu si tu recules de devant
ils V être les OM regarde tu recules les
ombres sont un peu loin
malheureusement et tu vois les ombres
sont
derrière les chameaux là c'est ça voilà
voilà tiens ce qu'on voulait tout à
l'heure une
intro on avait dit tout à l'heure en
dochant
très beau leur truc bleu dans le vent là
pas'abiller comme ça ça encore plus beau
ça bouge
vachement
on un petit contrejour de l'autre
côté
bien
cło attention au
souffle regarde un peu ça regarde un peu
où ils vont
là
B pas mal
ça
c'est bien c'est bien le mec qui ti
c'est bien le mec c'est bon c'est
bon
guule son piedil voil c'est bien ça
c'est bien c'est bien c'est
bien
j les pieds pasant c'est bien
voilà voilà voilà génial génial
doucement
doucementy le
truc allez
monte camé un peu à gauche la gauche
c'est le vent qui vole et tout c'est
magnifique
ça c'est superbe superbe les
enfants superbe superbe superbe superbe
super voil monte mon monte monte c'est
bien
ça contre jour c'est B on va commencer
écarte-toi écartetoi
[Musique]
écour superbe superbe
superbetion déjà
d'ailleurs c'est beau ça super plan ça
les enfants
hein vre connard qui est pas derrière oh
là là là là lui en un casse-couille de
fremire
lui
est-ce que je pourrais voir un peu
hauteur par
derrière